hello everyone and welcome back to game
sports coverage of e3 2017 joining
myself and Cali on the stage is mark
Cerny here to talk about NAT - welcome
thank you uh should we go into the
trailer you fall in love didn't you
trailer for neck - yes let's take a look
it makes a million robot clones of
themselves I mean who does that
stop whatever it is I'm in awesome
[Music]
I'm impressed
little trick I talk
whoa go
really Willie
a little bit about that music choice yes
ah
Willie won't go by 1970s glam rock band
the sweet and don't ask me why that the
game music is is is very different the
game music is more Hollywood it's more
cinematic Anthony Willis is the composer
but the trailer team thought that would
be fun
it was different it's a different flavor
from its a little whimsical yes it is
fun it is a whimsical trailer for sure
yeah yeah I mean let's jump right into
it I'm curious because you've compared
the original knack to you know cut amore
Dhamma C with a little crash you're a
little God of War is an act to UM does
it resemble anything else is it along a
similar line it's quite a bit different
than the first game very frankly the
first game kind of a mixed reaction so
we were very careful to listen to the
feedback whether it be reviews or boards
or tweets or play tests and I think much
stronger game as a result we focused on
variety a lot so a knack one mostly
combat knack to is combat and
platforming as well and some puzzles
here you're seeing a bit of the
platforming the puzzles you know I won't
say they're the most complex things but
definitely there's that three minutes of
trying to figure out what to do
sometimes in that Eureka moment that's
so satisfying also a couple different
modes of play like driving a tank I
think you saw that in the trailer sort
of break up the action of the game
so obviously designing puzzles and
designing performing is is an art really
because you have to be able to make sure
that the player understands what it is
they need to do is that the most
challenging part of the design process
um managing the the variety and making
sure it's sort of all turns into a
cohesive whole can be a bit tricky
sometimes with the platforming the team
approached it from a rather interesting
direction they wanted objects with
unpredictable motion
so that you know you'd have to really
look at and try to figure out not just
platforms in space going up and down
there left and right but something you
know sliding in or out or rotating and I
think that's paid off they also wanted
to have it be very grounded not you know
20 years ago maybe you could get away
with random platforms floating in space
but at this point gamers expect that
it's part of the game universe whether
it's you know the water wheels that are
powering a city or the inside of some
giant machine or the like mm-hmm um and
just really quickly going back to
listening to feedback uh what was one of
the main pieces of feedback that you
guys took into account going into nack -
well we also got a lot of feedback about
the combat you know nack one I was
trying to kind of make sort of an
on-ramp where people who had never held
DualShock before could still play the
game turn out well probably obviously in
retrospect not to be the sort of thing
that would make a typical gamer happy so
this time much more traditional approach
combat a lot of depth we start out maybe
double the moveset complexity of nack 1
and it just goes from there you you
learn moves in the storyline you can
collect relic energy from treasure
chests and any enemy you defeat that's
the blue stuff they're picking up right
now and you can use that to buy upgrades
to your moves or new moves or the
ability to chain your moves into combos
and did you and your team have to you
know how what's the process of balancing
because you know obviously you still
want to include the kind of player who
maybe isn't as familiar with this kind
of game how do you go about balancing
more complexity for the traditional
gamer but also something that's
accessible so we've got easy normal hard
and very hard pretty much if you're
picking very hard or hard you did that
that's on you for easy you can pretty
much get through the game with a couple
kinks kicks in a punch or two and for
the platforming you actually take a
different path oh and you bypass the
platforming the tricky platforming
sections because you need to do and some
of those about 60 jobs I mean we have
lots of checkpoints there in the middle
but a lot of the people who are playing
on
easy I've never picked up a DualShock
controller before and so they're still
trying to work out how to go in a
straight line I mean this is this is
very much a family game we want to have
a co-op audience as well and so it's
quite possible that either the you know
the parent or the five-year-old child
in coop is literally picking up a
DualShock for the first time ever what I
like about the coop is that there's the
interaction between the two characters a
lot of the times in Cub you'll have both
of you sort of on your own side of the
screen each sort of working towards the
same goal but not really working
together was that a big thing that you
were thinking about we're trying to make
it very involving for the coop
definitely so in the platforming
sections one players getting ahead you
can just hit r2 and you can warp to
wherever the player is or for combat we
have some specific combat moves that are
Justin co-op we noticed in the play test
that kids particularly brothers would
just start hitting each other really
well not in real life
no so we managed to turn that into
actual gameplay so if you know you're
playing as redneck and you start
punching blue Knack you are knocking
parts out of blue neck and that is an
attack they'll go out and hit enemies so
when you do like a multi punch on the
other knack that's spraying parts like a
machine gun across the environment oh
that's cool so rewarding those kinds of
kids rather than taking that option away
as long as they don't take it into the
real world
yeah in the real world you don't turn to
machine gun though Wow unfortunately um
but when in making neck - given that the
amount of games that are coming out on
the PlayStation 4 now do you feel like
you and your team obviously oh that the
lead system architect for the
PlayStation falls what have you learnt
about the machine itself over time and
what improvements can you make - neck -
by you know third understanding its
architecture well to be honest you know
the early game work was great because it
did it did teach me a lot about how the
hardware turned out so knack and the
launch titles at this point I'm mostly
being director on on on knack because
I'm trying to keep that skill set active
I got some very good advice when
starting the hardware work which is
never stop creating games now if you if
you
on both sides of it you're going to have
much better insights on what needs to go
into a console mm-hmm fascinating I'm
sorry I feel like I cut you off earlier
- oh no that was my was my up Michael no
we're good um yeah so I totally lost my
question no that's okay um I'm just
really curious though about like because
the gameplay is different um and you're
still targeting both audiences right but
like Mac - how do you go from something
that had like how do you move on to a
new project when you come from something
that had mixed results like how does
your team recover from that well yeah we
went out you know gamers are great
because they they care about games and
they will tell you what they think and
so you know if you have the strength to
go out there and and read all of it
really in terms of what you're creating
and how much better it can get the
results can be amazing and this isn't
just knack if you look at the first in
the second crash bandicoot which I know
is 20 years ago but the difference in
quality between those games was
extraordinary
even uncharted you know uncharted 2 was
game of the year but uncharted 1 was not
quite at that same level and getting
consumer feedback was a huge part of
that
mm-hm but nowadays with social media the
consumer feedback I guess you can't
really ignore it even if you tried but
how is your relationship between
developers and gamers changed even since
the days of crash well in days of crash
you couldn't really go on the boards and
get quite the level of feedback you
today they're helpful you know even
frankly tweets are helpful you know if
you can't have the most insightful
commentary about the shortcomings of a
game at 140 characters but certainly
somebody can say I expected this thing
to have lot of platforming and I didn't
have it and that's good feedback for the
team and it shows that they're
passionate enough right - yeah come and
tell you I mean they're they're doing it
because they care most of them Muslim
about how long is neck - actually I'm
just that's a totally hard right but I
am curious knack - the playtime is
roughly
the same length an AK one was but
because we have so many more checkpoints
and there's so much more of a guaranteed
progress for the game the game itself is
quite a bit longer in terms of features
or miles or however you want to count it
then knack one was oh okay so you can
get more like more mileage out of it
yeah we're going to a lot more places in
that same amount of time as well mark
thank you so much for joining us up when
is not good to of it Oh
launching September 5th not very long so
exciting well thank you so much for
joining thank you for having me I'm for
more from e3 2017 make sure to keep your
eyes peeled to gamespot.com